joined by Phil Osborne Air Marshal
philosophy former Chief of Defense
intelligence for the UK Phil thanks for
being with us let's look at where we are
on uh as we enter week three of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine what's it
looking like on the ground to take a
look at this wide map of the situation
so I think if we step back just for a
moment
um remember this is not where Russia
planned to be day two day three the
expected decapitation take care of
replace the government start to build a
land bridge between Crimea and the Hans
Don ask what we're actually now seeing
is a stagnating Russian slog against
really spirited really capable Ukrainian
resistance yeah we can see where the
ukrainians are still holding those
cities but the fight for the South does
seem to be moving uh slightly more
differently let's take a closer look at
the southern picture right now and talk
us through the Russian events that have
been made and we've got there the only
city that has been taken by Russia the
city of Kirsten tell us what's happening
in the fight for the South so what we're
seeing is Russia probably executing what
was originally part of the plan that
join up of the Crimea with the if you
like the the Russian controlled
previously Russian controlled states in
the East
um that's going on today
more success in the south and north but
not nearly as successful as the Russians
would hope to be if we look to the West
we can see Russia almost certainly
trying to take Odessa to cut off Ukraine
from the Black Sea which will have a
pretty significant economic impact from
a Ukrainian but also from a Global
Perspective and then coming right to
join up with forces around donask and
the hansk and that's why we're seeing
the particularly difficult particularly
dangerous damaging conflict going on
around Marriott Port yeah we saw those
pictures yesterday evening didn't we of
the strike on that maternity hospital in
mariopol I mean how is that a strategy
that's going to help the Russians win
this war by bombing a hospital so I
think from a Mario poll perspective
we're seeing in maripole exactly what we
would be seeing in other Ukrainian
cities what we already have seen
um should we be shocked yes disgusted
yes surprised no this demonstrates
Russia's lack of military options
Ukraine Armed Forces gone into the City
and therefore or they really have got to
try and take those cities or starve them
out that also gives the West a problem
because it puts the West on the spot
there's a humanitarian challenge for the
west and this therefore is quite a
useful political tool from a Russian
perspective okay let's take a look at
the campaign further north now as we've
known for the past two weeks there is
that Russian Convoy that's moving in on
Kiev 40 miles long but hasn't really got
very far what's happened with that Phil
so it tell us about the tactics to try
and take so it's a it's a 40 mile
traffic jam and it probably wasn't just
one cornball it was a number of convoys
which have now come together that feels
quite stagnant although Russia is trying
hard to to recover that logistical
nightmare where it's also applying
pressure around Kiev is coming from the
East as we can see on on the map trying
to encircle the capital trying to put it
under significant amount of pressure
what's also noticeable probably about
this theater is the Russians have
finally admitted using the toss one
alpha thermobaric weapon to the north
and east of Kiev yeah and we think
that's about where it was used tell us
more about this toss19 Alpha so so this
is a multi-launch rocket system but
what's different about it is it it
generates conventional blast so it's
really highly significant blast effects
far beyond normal artillery or delivered
Munitions if you like it's a it's a
conventional weapon of mass destruction
the the kind of ways to use it under law
of arm conflict you'd have to be only
using it against enemy of troops if you
like military personnel and in a way
that didn't produce
disproportionate effects certainly you
shouldn't be using it if there's a risk
of Civilian casualties and the use of
this weapon in any built up area that
risk is clearly there yeah and this
comes after we've heard of course about
that strike on Mario pole and talk
yesterday of chemical weapons biological
weapons factories
so the the risk of escalation is always
going to be there we've seen a Russian
narrative preparing the ground for
potential use of chemical weapons
talking about the US and Ukraine having
chemical weapons facilities in Ukraine
um I don't think I think we can put no
Credence on that at all but what that
does is that starts to introduce some
level of unbalance to an already
difficult narrative from a western point
of view it also gives the Russians cover
to use chemical weapons in that Dreadful
circumstance that they think is the only
option available to okay Air Marshal
philsborne thank you very much for that
move from you throughout the day thank